how you doing so
much for coming on the show we were so
excited that you were
here and before we start i have to ask
what your message is to young girls like
you
who have a dream but don't know where to
begin
follow your dreams you know break those
glass ceilings
be resilient be strong and you'll get
there
oh chef ro i mean you really are the
example so it's really amazing to ask
life advice from you um okay
will you take us through what we are
making today the title is my favorite
so this recipe is called don't be a jerk
and it's basically
a crab crab cake that i marinated in
jerk marinade seasoning
and why is this dish meaningful to you
so you know i was raised by a single
mother i don't know my father
but what i do know is that he's jamaican
right so i just really wanted to tap
into the caribbean side of myself
i love it okay we're really excited to
learn
this meaningful personal dish from you
that really is original so
teach us chef ro what's first yes
okay so easy i have my crab meat in the
bowl
all right i um have some lemon juice in
there ready
i'm gonna add my one egg to it the egg
is gonna be kind of like a binder
um i have my beautiful pre-made jerk
marinade
in here this is going to be the
seasoning to our crab cake it makes it
extremely moist it makes it extremely
spicy
so we want to add all of that in there
as well of course rich crackers risk
crackers are my favorite
so the wrists give it some texture and
it also gives a little bit of sweetness
because that jerk is so spicy because of
that scotch bonnet pepper
right so i got all of my ritz in there
and of course we're going to season this
with some salt
give it some love and finish it with
some black pepper
right and then we're going to mix this
all together drew so
i have my gloves ready if you want if
you have a rubber spatula
if you want to get it dirty with your
hands it's all up to you
i do have a rubber spatula ro i actually
just made it
and it says make something beautiful
love drew
so i like that i like that so i'm just
mixing this all together i'm using jumbo
lump crab
so you don't really want it to be
shreddy but you just want to mix it
together so everything holds together
so um what i have here is my pre-made
crab cakes
okay i used a ring mold just because i
wanted the crab cakes to be the same
size as my hawaiian toasted rolls right
once it's formed in the ring mold you're
going to take it and you're going to put
it on that plate of
panko and that's going to be like that
extra crispiness on the outside of our
crab cake
so i'm just going to take this and move
it on your hands
you want to push out yeah you can do
that you can slide right on there and
then use your hands to push it
out of the ring mold exactly right and
then slide it up
perfect that's exactly what i did for
the home cook to do such a professional
restaurant
level like move like a ring mold is
really exciting
and then do i want to add the panko on
top as well
yes so i put panko on top and then i
flip it over
just to kind of pressure press it down
so that it has this nice coating
right and then that's going to stay in
the refrigerator for about 30 minutes
minimum
or overnight ideally so that the egg
binder
the rich crackers everything can just
solidify together
so that you have a beautiful crab cake
so we're going to go right
into our i'm using corn oil
you want to go until it's golden brown
and delicious
so about 30 seconds on each side so drew
drew once you get golden brown and
delicious i just want to come and i want
to blot this
on a paper towel just to get that excess
fat off
okay i'm going to land right on the
bottom of my hawaiian toasted bread
so what we did was we made a jerk mayo
right because i like my sandwiches with
mayo i made the mayo from scratch
so i had my oil my one egg yolk and i
added some of that jerk marinade
that we made in the beginning for the
crab cake and i'm just going to lightly
put this on top of
my bun and then a little tomato
would you like me to put whatever you
want you can get creative here
exactly chef rhode how would you like me
uh to pile
in what order bread it's all up to you
chef
this is where your creativity comes in
you can use any kind
any anything you can use onion you don't
have to do onion you can do whatever you
would like you could do pickle
whatever you prefer so you make it how
you would like to eat it
i'm i'm gonna say that i really am
piling on i
i'm a i like the accoutrement i like
onion and um i like what
feels like a restaurant burger right
and i can't wait to try this crab cake
okay here i go
you ready you go for it first let me
know
oh my gosh this is incredible
this is the best crab cake i've ever had
in my life and i'm a crowd cake fan
thank you i really appreciate that i'm
glad you like this drew
chef rowe i'm so honored do you think we
could do this again
uh listen call call me i'm here it's a
date
it's a date drew i'll see you soon